in Buch 2, Kapitel 5, was die Anima
Aristoteles einführt, eine Unterscheidung
zwischen zwei Bedeutungen der Idee der
Möglichkeit, die er für
notwendig hält, um zu verstehen, was er
das Prinzip des Lebens oder der Seele nennt, das
Beispiel, mit dem er die
Unterscheidbarkeit der zweifachen Weise einführt  was
man von einem Menschen sagen kann, dass sie
zu theoretischem Verständnis fähig ist,
jemand kann
in einem Sinne als fähig zu theoretischem Verständnis bezeichnet werden
, was nicht impliziert, dass sie
irgendein bestimmtes theoretisches
Wissen wie Grammatikkenntnisse erlernt und erworben hat
der Grund dafür  dass man sagen kann, dass sie zu
theoretischem Verständnis fähig ist, ist
nicht, dass sie tatsächlich etwas Wissen hat,
sondern dass sie als Mensch einer
Spezies angehört, die zu theoretischem Verständnis fähig ist,
theoretisches Wissen ist
für sie eine bloße Möglichkeit, das heißt, es ist
in keinem Sinne  eine Realität in einem anderen Sinne, von
jemandem kann gesagt werden,
dass er in einem Sinne
, der dies impliziert, zu theoretischem Verständnis fähig ist  Da sie tatsächlich
einige Kenntnisse erlernt und erworben hat,
ist Grammatikkenntnis für sie keine bloße Möglichkeit mehr,
sondern in gewissem Sinne
eine Wirklichkeit, dies bedeutet jedoch nicht, dass
sie, die
in diesem Sinne theoretisch verstehen kann,
die erworbene Fähigkeit auch tatsächlich ausübt
Wenn sie weitere Aspekte des
Zitterns untersucht, könnte sie zum Beispiel
schlafen oder einen Film ansehen, gibt es immer noch ein
Gefühl, in dem ihr Wissen über
Grammatik eine Möglichkeit ist, die
nicht die tatsächlichen Augen sind, sondern ein Gefühl, das
voraussetzt, dass es dieses
Wissen auch gibt  eine Realität für sie in neueren
Debatten darüber, wie
die
Unterscheidungskraft der menschlichen Lebensform oder der menschlichen
Spezies richtig charakterisiert werden kann, wurde die aristotelische Unterscheidung
zwischen diesen beiden Sinnen für
Potentialität von Autoren aufgegriffen,
die die Idee betonen wollten, dass die
Unterscheidungskraft  der menschlichen Spezies ist
weitgehend eine Frage der Praxis und
Bildung in ihrer prominentesten
zeitgenössischen Version  weiter finden wir in der
Position von Tron McDowell, der argumentiert,
dass die Merkmale, die
Menschen von
allen nichtmenschlichen Tieren unterscheiden, paradoxerweise größtenteils Teil
ihrer zweiten Natur sind,
aber die gleiche aristotelische
Unterscheidung zwischen zwei Sinnen für
Potenzial wurde auch von
Autoren verwendet  die für die
gegenteilige Position argumentieren wollen, wollen diese Autoren
argumentieren, dass die Unterscheidungskraft
der menschlichen Gattung nur
mit dem Naturbegriff verstanden werden kann,
wonach die Unterscheidungskraft der
menschlichen Gattung bereits und
grundsätzlich eine Angelegenheit ihrer ursprünglichen
Natur ist  und diese Position wurde
unter anderem von Mike Lee
Thompson, Philippa Food und Elizabeth
Anscombe verteidigt, nachdem Marty
Thomas vorgeschlagen hat, dass ich die erstere
Position anspruchsvolle aristotelische ISM
und die letztere Position naive
aristotelische ISM nennen werde. Die Debatte zwischen
raffinierter und naiver aristotelischer ISM ist
es nicht  eine Debatte darüber, was
heute als th bezeichnet wird  Das Platzierungsproblem ist
nicht die Frage, wo
die Idee der Rationalität in erster Natur
oder zweiter Natur zu platzieren ist, als ob beide Parteien
das gleiche Konzept von erster und zweiter
Natur hätten, sondern es ist eine Debatte darüber, wie
man die Idee von a richtig versteht
menschliche Natur Im Folgenden werde ich
in zwei oder drei Schritten vorgehen. Ich werde
zunächst die Gemeinsamkeiten beider
Parteien der Debatte darlegen, indem ich zeige, wie
beide versuchen, die gleiche
Schwierigkeit zu bewältigen. Ich werde dann auf
die Hauptabstraktion hinweisen, die jede Position
darstellt  Konfrontiert mit in den Augen des
anderen im letzten Teil werde ich dann
eine Version der naiven aristotelischen
ISM verteidigen, die eine bestimmte Vorstellung davon untergräbt,
was es bedeutet, eine erste Natur zu haben
, die meiner Meinung nach die Kanalisation der Debatte
oder die Verwirrung zwischen ihnen ist  so
definiert Aristoteles eine Seele als die Form
eines Lebewesens qua Lebewesen es ist das
, was die Frage beantwortet,
wodurch dies ein Lebewesen
ist, also irgendein Lebewesen  Während
Lebewesen nach dieser Definition eine Seele haben,
glaubt Aristoteles,
zwischen drei verschiedenen Arten von Seelen unterscheiden zu können
und den Begriff einer Lebensform, wie
sie von Michael Thompson verwendet wird,
sowie eine von John McDowell nicht mehr verwendete
zu erfassen  Die aristotelische Idee einer
Seele, also die Idee einer Form, die
in der Idee von Leobens Form verwendet wird, ist unsere
Lebensform streng genommen die aristotelische
Idee einer Form, aber nichtsdestotrotz
erhebt das, was es eine Lebensform ist, so und
Arizona denkt das  er kann
zwischen drei Arten von Seelen unterscheiden und so können
wir sagen, dass unsere Seele glaubt,
zwischen drei Formen solcher
Lebensformen unterscheiden zu können, und er nennt sie die
feuchtere Lebensform, die tierische
Lebensform und die rationale
Lebensform, so my  Thema ist zu verstehen, was
es bedeutet, die
Unterscheidungskraft der menschlichen Lebensform
in Bezug auf ihre Rationalität zu charakterisieren, da dieser
Begriff in der formalen
Charakterisierung der rationalen Lebensform oder Estel
c  Abgesehen von Neuseeland
teilen sowohl der raffinierte als auch der naive Aristotelismus die
Idee, dass die aristotelische Unterscheidung
zwischen zwei Bedeutungen der Idee der
Potenzialität der Schlüssel zur Bestätigung von
Behauptungen ist, die beide Parteien gleichermaßen überzeugend finden
erstens, dass die
menschliche Spezies einen
gegenüber jeder
anderen Spezies formal unverwechselbaren Charakter hat, zweitens, dass kleine Menschenkinder
noch keine der
Fähigkeiten aufweisen, die
die Rationalität eines erwachsenen Menschen kennzeichnen,
wie das Denken und Sprechen einer Sprache
Gründe geben und fragen oder
Versprechen halten usw. Ich liebe Ihre Skizze, wie
Befürworter des raffinierten
Aristotelischen von der australischen Unterscheidung
zwischen zwei Bedeutungen der Idee der
Potenzialität Gebrauch machen, um beide Ansprüche zu untermauern
, die gemäß unserem
zivilen ISM rationale Tiere sind
Ergebnis eines Erziehungsprozesses,
der ein bloß sinnliches Tier
verwandelt, das  h ist nur potentiell mit
jenen Fähigkeiten verbunden, die Rationalität konstituieren, bis hin
zu einem Tier, das
diese Fähigkeiten tatsächlich besitzt.
Nach dieser Position bezeichnet
der Begriff Rationalität ein
intrinsisch selbstbewusstes System von
Fähigkeiten, dh Fähigkeiten, die
man nicht verarbeiten kann, ohne sich seiner
bewusst zu sein  deren Besitz ist nach
MacDowell die paradigmatische Fähigkeit
, die dieses System von Fähigkeiten ausmacht,
die Fähigkeit, Konzepte in
Urteilen zu verwenden, deren Inhalt man
verstehen kann und für die man
Gründe angeben, nach Gründen fragen und
Gründe ins Zentrum stellen kann  Präzision
ist die Idee, dass die Rolle von Praxis
und Bildung darin besteht, eine
Transformation von einem Individuum,
das dieses System rationaler
Fähigkeiten nur potenziell verarbeitet, in ein Es-wäre-
Individuum herbeizuführen, das es tatsächlich verarbeitet,
und hier eine repräsentative
Passage von MacDowell, aber er
artikuliert dies  Position Tränke ist
unsere  Nummer 3 Menschliche Individualität ist kein
Vertrauen, biologisch, nicht erschöpft durch die
Einzigartigkeit eines bestimmten menschlichen Tieres,
ein vollwertiges menschliches Individuum, ein
freier Akteur
eine gemeinschaftliche Lebensform
ist für ein zufriedenstellendes
Verständnis von
Grundansprechbarkeit erforderlich Grundansprechbarkeit
kennzeichnet ein vollwertiges menschliches Individuum
nicht mehr nur als biologisch
partikuläres, sondern als
metaphysisch neuartiges Wesen, das
nach dieser Vorstellung nur noch kleine Kinder sind
potentiell rationale Tiere im
Sinne von Tieren, die beim Tun, was sie
tun, ein Bewusstsein der Gründe dafür manifestieren, aus
denen sie tun, was sie tun, ist
es ihnen möglich,
in diesem Sinne rational und selbstbewusst
zu werden und dadurch zu einem Wesen zu werden, das nicht
mehr ist  ein nur biologisch bestimmtes,
aber ein frei handelndes Wesen, aber was sie tun,
solange sie kleine Kinder sind, ist es.  Es ist nicht
eine Manifestation der metaphysisch
gleichen Art, zu der sie gehören, wenn sie
das erfahren haben, was Miguel
Teilnahme an einer gemeinschaftlichen Lebensform nennt,
oder wie ich kurz sagen werde, wenn sie
Praxis und Bildung durchlaufen haben.
Zwei Punkte sind hier entscheidend, erstens wie
diese Darstellung  beschreibt den Anfang und das
Ende der Erziehung sie beginnt mit einer
bloßen Menge des Besonderen und endet mit
einer freien Person metaphysisch gedacht
es gibt keinen Unterschied zwischen kleinen
Kindern und nichtmenschlichen Tieren die
Grundprinzipien der Aktivitäten
werden in Begriffen von Fähigkeiten beschrieben
die noch nicht das
oben erwähnte System von Fähigkeiten
beinhalten, die Rationalität konstituieren, und
wie sie sich technisch die Rolle
der Bildung vorstellt, nämlich als einen Prozess,
der eine metaphysische
Transformation von einem nicht rationalen Wesen
in ein rationales Wesen bewirkt, so die Idee des
menschlichen Kindes  ist eine Entwicklungsstufe, in
der das menschliche Individuum eine
metaphysische Transformation erfährt
Der folgende Gedanke setzt voraus, dass er erkennt, dass
der Begriff des Menschen eine
substantielle Einheit beschreibt, die
durch einen Begriff der Animalität,
der seine Materie beschreibt, und der Begriff der
Rationalität, der seine Form beschreibt, der
Begriff des Menschen nach
dieser Konzeption analysiert werden kann  ist der begriff der
einheit dieser beiden begriffe, aber wie
genau sind diese beiden begriffe
auf einen bezogen und sind nach dieser
konzeption
nun hochentwickelte künste der italienische ismus
denkt über diese beziehung zweierlei
, in einer hinsicht versteht er sie als eine
Einheit, die irgendwie analog ist zu der, die
wir in der Beziehung zwischen der
Form einer Statue und ihrer Materie finden Die
Materie Die Materie einer Statue, zum
Beispiel ein Stück Holz, ist so, dass es
die Form einer Statue
gemäß dieser Analogie annehmen kann  Diese Position gilt
in zweierlei Hinsicht, damit ein Stück
Holz die Form einer Statue erhält, ist ein
Baumeister erforderlich, bei dem die Form
der Statue
wirksam ist, wie z  dass er sich unter
anderem die entsprechenden Werkzeuge und
Techniken aneignet, die er braucht
, um dem Holz diese Form geben zu können, dies ist
vergleichbar mit der Situation der menschlichen Versuchung
für den Menschen, der versucht, die Form der Rationalität zu erhalten, die
ein Erzieher oder eine gemeinschaftliche
Lebensform benötigt  in dem die
Form der Rationalität so wirksam ist,
dass er oder jene gemeinschaftliche Lebensform sich
die geeigneten
Werkzeuge und Techniken aneignet, um
dem Kind diese Form zu geben, daraus folgt,
dass es möglich ist, dass ein Stück
Holz niemals die Form erhält  Form einer Statue, wie
es ebenso möglich ist, dass ein menschliches
Kind nie vernünftig wird, aber
gleichzeitig will die raffinierte aristotelische ISM
die Beziehung
zwischen Form und Materie beim Menschen denken
, die viel intimer ist
als  bei Artefakten ist das
Empfangen der Form der Rationalität
das Empfangen einer Form, mit der das,
was diese Form empfängt, bereits
gedanklich damit vereint ist  ch erhält
die Form der Rationalität ist ein Mensch
, das heißt, es ist etwas, das bereits
unter den Begriff fällt, dessen Inhalt
in Bezug auf tierische Materie und
rationale Form analysiert wird. Daher ist die Idee des Menschen
nach dieser Darstellung die Idee
eines Tieres, das  unter einen Begriff fällt
, der den Begriff der Rationalität enthält,
aber nicht als etwas, was irgendein Tier
, das unter den Begriff des Menschen fällt
, bereits verwirklicht, nur
weil es ein Mensch ist,
sondern etwas, mit dem das menschliche Tier
darin begrifflich vereint ist  es
beschreibt die Form dieses Tieres in seinem
voll entwickelten Zustand ein Mensch
nach dieser Darstellung für das, was
unter einem Begriff steht, dessen vollständige Instantiierung
die Umwandlung eines lediglich
biologisch bestimmten in ein
Tier erfordert. Die folgenden beiden Behauptungen sind somit
maßgeblich für diesen Begriff
Erstens ist es möglich, das
Konzept eines Menschen zu instanziieren, ohne
Rationalität zu instanziieren, und zweitens
summen  eine Entwicklung ist die fortschreitende
Verwirklichung einer Form in einem Tier,
das als solches
diese Form noch nicht real verkörpert, mit dem es
aber begrifflich vereint ist, so dass es dieser
Form potentiell gemäß dieser
Position die Idee des menschlichen Lebens und
die Idee von hat  ein rationales Leben sind
in ihrer Bedeutung unterschiedlich, obwohl der Begriff des
menschlichen Lebens den Begriff eines
rationalen Lebens enthält, ist er damit nicht identisch
, denn man kann jetzt ein Mensch sein,
ohne ein rationales Tier zu sein, wenn die
aristotelische ISM argumentiert, dass die
metaphysische Art die sind
vollwertiger Mensch sich nicht
von dem unterscheidet, den kleine
Kinder instanziieren das liegt nicht
daran, dass sie denken, dass kleine
Kinder bereits mit jenen Fähigkeiten geboren werden
, die nach anspruchsvollem
Aristoteles im Laufe der Erziehung erworben werden müssen,
sondern dies ist
so  weil sie leugnen, dass der Begriff
des Menschen in
etwas anderes als das
Unterscheidbare zerlegt werden kann  Der Begriff der
Rationalität, den ein vollwertiger
Mensch instanziiert, ist nicht der Begriff
einer Form,
die in einem Leben, das nicht das menschliche Leben ist, auch anders instanziiert werden könnte,
sondern der Begriff der
Rationalität, wie er das
menschliche Leben charakterisiert  Konzept von nichts
anderem als dem Konzept der menschlichen Form
Träger der menschlichen Lebensform,
die Träger dieser Lebensform sind,
verwirklichen diese Form also in
allem, was sie sind, und tun dies gemäß
der naiven aristotelischen ISM, die von einem
vernünftigen Tier oder einem spricht  frei handelnd spricht nicht
von einer Art, die andere
Arten als die menschliche Art haben könnte,
noch spricht es von einer Art, die
einige Menschen, nämlich die Gebildeten
, in ihrem Leben instanziieren, sondern es
ist eine abstrakte Art, von der
menschlichen Lebensform zu sprechen  es ist abstrakt
, indem es von jenen Faktoren abstrahiert,
kraft derer der Begriff dieser
Lebensform der Begriff einer Wirklichkeit
ist, die der Begriff des Individuums ist  Duale,
die diese Form manifestieren, bevor ich
unseren Blick auf die Probleme
richten werde, mit denen beide Positionen in den
Augen des jeweils anderen konfrontiert sind,
lassen Sie mich zunächst die Gemeinsamkeiten skizzieren, die
beide Varianten des Aristotelischen ism
die Idee teilen, dass das Unterschiedliche nicht das
Ich ist.  Es tut mir leid, dass die Unterscheidungskraft
des Menschen in
Begriffen eines Unterschieds in der Form verstanden werden sollte. Dieser Gedanke
stellt beide in Gegensatz zu den
meisten zeitgenössischen Philosophien, denn es bedeutet
zu leugnen, dass der anthropologische
Unterschied in Begriffen spezifischer Fähigkeiten erfasst werden kann
, die als  menschliche
Prozesse zusätzlich zu denen, die
nichtmenschliche Tiere besitzen, was
die meisten zeitgenössischen Debatten dominiert
, ist der Unterschied ihrer Meinung nach einer im Sinne
des Einheitsprinzips, aufgrund
dessen es etwas gibt, das so
gut wie ein Thema einer Vielfalt darstellen kann
von lebenswichtigen Operationen, das ist das
Prinzip der Einheit, aufgrund dessen
es so etwas wie ein Lebewesen gibt,
ein Mensch ist kein Tier plus
in  sagen, sondern eine besondere Art
, ein Tier zu sein, so wie ein Tier
keine Pflanze ist, plus einige weitere Fähigkeiten, so dass
dies die Idee impliziert, dass die Konzepte
, die die lebenswichtigen Vorgänge von
Tieren bezeichnen, wie zum Beispiel Essen,
Trinken, Verdauen, Wahrnehmen,
Reproduzieren, Schlafen und Wachsein usw
haben im Falle eines rationalen Tieres nicht die gleiche Bedeutung
wie im Falle eines
nicht rationalen Tieres, so
dass es für die Bedeutung dieser Konzepte eine formale Unterscheidung
zwischen
Mensch und nicht-menschlichem und männlichem Team gibt
Für sie ist es abhängig von
der Form der Lebensform, die das
betreffende Tier aufweist, also die Vorstellung,
dass ja, drei verschiedene Arten von Seelen
oder drei verschiedene Formen von
Lebensformen
Aristoteles drückt dies aus, indem er sagt, dass das
Leben auf viele Arten gesprochen wird  was es
bedeutet, ein Lebewesen zu sein, ist also anders,
wenn das betreffende Individuum
eine vegetative Lebensform aufweist, es ist
wiederum anders, wenn es eine aufweist
tierische Lebensform, und es ist wieder
anders, wenn sie eine rationale
Lebensform darstellt, also ist der Test von Aristoteles,
die menschliche Lebensform als eine
rationale Lebensform zu denken, das heißt als eine
Lebensform, deren verbindendes Prinzip das ist, was
er ist  nennt den Intellekt Die Debatte
zwischen anspruchsvollem und
naivem Aristotelismus ist eine Debatte darüber, wie
diese Konzeption richtig zu verstehen ist, was
es bedeutet, den Intellekt
oder die Rationalität als die Form einer
Lebensform zu betrachten, so dass der anspruchsvolle Aristotelismus
die Idee entfaltet, die der Intellekt ist
Die Form einer unverwechselbaren Lebensform
wie folgt An die intellektuelle
Rationalität eines Fußes als die Form einer
Lebensform zu denken, bedeutet zu denken,
dass es eine Lebensform gibt, die von Individuen definiert wird
, die sich in einer Prozession
mächtiger Konzepte befinden  und Urteilen,
die die vitalen Fähigkeiten derer
, die diese Macht besitzen, zu
selbstbewussten und daher rationalen Wesen
vereinen, berührt die paradigmatische Aktivität dieser Wesen
Denn in Berührung
manifestieren sie ihre Lebensform in der sie
definierenden Weise, so dass die Vorstellung
einer solchen Kraft nach dieser
Auffassung nicht beinhaltet, dass diese
Kraft auch das vereinigende
Prinzip ganz anderer
Lebenskräfte als derjenigen sein könnte, die die ausmachen
Menschliche Lebensform Natürlich ist die menschliche
Lebensform die einzige rationale
Lebensform, die wir Menschen mit
Sicherheit kennen, aber wir können logisch nicht ausschließen,
dass es andere Arten rationalen
Lebens gibt, die lebensnotwendige Fähigkeiten mit sich bringen
, die uns bisher völlig unbekannt sind  und
dennoch einen Intellekt haben, so
naiv ist Aristotelisch, manche Dinge sind
hoch entwickelter Aristotelismus, also ist
diese Auffassung von Rationalität gemäß unserer naiven Staatsfremdheit
inkohärent, warum wohl ihre Prämisse ist, dass
das Konzept der Rationalität das
Konzept einer Macht ist, die es tut
keinen bestimmten Begriff von den
Bedingungen ihrer Verwirklichung enthält, ist es
der Begriff einer Macht, die als solche
nicht gilt  Ein spezifisches
Verständnis davon, wie dieses
Konzept eine Realität beschreibt, was erforderlich ist, damit
diese Fähigkeit zum Geschwätz und
zu Konzepten in einer Vielzahl von Handlungen aktualisiert wird, ist
noch nicht in dem
Verständnis dieser Kraft zu unserer Macht enthalten, sondern in diesem
Verständnis der Kraft für Konzepte
und Treach Munz nämlich als etwas, das
sich tatsächlich in einer bestimmten Lebenstätigkeit verwirklicht,
erfordert, dass wir uns
diese Kraft als die Form einer bestimmten
Materie vorstellen,
zum Beispiel irdische tierische Materie, wenn
wir diese Kraft als die Form
irdischer tierischer Materie dann für alle denken  Wir
haben über diese Materie gelernt, dass Übung
und Bildung erforderlich sind, damit diese
Kraft in einem Individuum verwirklicht werden kann,
das durch solche Materie konstituiert wird, so dass
gemäß dem naiven Aristotelismus der
anspruchsvolle Aristotelismus zu der Annahme gelangt ist
, dass die Tatsache, dass ein menschliches
Individuum Übung und Bildung benötigt
denn die vollständige Instanziierung der menschlichen
Lebensform ist eine kontingente Tatsache über diese
Individuen, es ist eine Tatsache  dass die Menschen
über sich selbst lernen mussten, diese
Darstellung der aristotelischen Lehre ist
jedoch inkohärent, sie ist inkohärent,
weil sie die Rolle
von Praxis und Bildung im menschlichen Leben nicht
auf nicht paradoxe Weise charakterisieren kann, weil
sie einerseits verpflichtet ist, darüber nachzudenken  der
Anspruch, den ein Mensch praktizieren und bilden
muss, um
seine Form als einen empirischen
Anspruch über den Menschen, der anders hätte sein können, vollständig zu verwirklichen, ist
jedoch der Einwand, wenn
man diesen Anspruch als einen empirischen
Anspruch über den Menschen betrachtet, an dem man sich nicht festhalten kann
auf die Wahrheit dieses Anspruchs, ohne
gleichzeitig die Möglichkeit
seines Inhalts zu leugnen, denn ihn für einen wahren
Anspruch zu halten, hieße zu denken, dass
es kein menschliches Individuum gegeben haben kann
, das die Form der Rationalität verwirklicht,
bevor sie erzogen wurden
Wenn es jedoch kein menschliches Individuum gab,
das die Form der Rationalität verwirklicht,
bevor es Bildung gab,
dann hätte es keine geben können  en Bildung überhaupt
erst, da Bildung
voraussetzt, dass diejenigen, die
andere erziehen, die
Form, die der Inhalt der Bildung ist, bereits kennen,
also um so viel wie die Möglichkeit der Bildung verstehen zu können,
deren Notwendigkeit man diese
Lehre beanspruchen will  Leugnen Sie die Wahrheit dieser
Behauptung, nämlich dass Bildung nicht
notwendig ist, so dass gemäß unserem naiven
Suetley-Anismus das Gesicht
irgendeines dieser Berichte resultiert oder auf
Koreanisch dieser Bericht aus der
Idee resultiert, dass es logisch möglich ist,
das Konzept des Intellekts
als zu entwirren  Es charakterisiert die Form einer
Lebensform aus dem Begriff der menschlichen
Lebensform. Diese Entflechtung ist unmöglich,
wenn man die
Idee, dass der Intellekt die Form einer
Lebensform ist, in der richtigen Weise versteht. Was
bedeutet es also zu verstehen
ihn richtig zu verstehen
bedeutet, zu leugnen, dass der Intellekt
eine Fähigkeit ist, geschweige denn eine Fähigkeit, die
sich unterschiedlich verwirklichen lässt  Je
nach konkreter Materie, deren Form es ist, ist die
als Form einer Lebensform begriffene Idee des Intellekts
nicht die
Idee einer individuellen Fähigkeit, weder eine
unter vielen noch eine grundlegende,
sondern die Idee einer früheren Eigenschaft  eine
Lebensform, die sie in
Begriffen ihrer Verwirklichungsweise spezifiziert, sie
charakterisiert die Lebensform, die sie
spezifiziert, als eine rationale, sie
spezifiziert, als eine, die
sich durch ein
so selbstbewusstes Selbstbewusstsein verwirklicht.  Bewusstsein ist nach dieser
Darstellung keine Macht, von der
gefragt werden kann, wie ein einzelnes Lebewesen
in den Besitz kommt, weil
es eine bestimmte Weise des Individuumseins charakterisiert,
in erster
Linie Träger einer rationalen Lebensform zu sein bedeutet
, ein zu sein  Person, die
ihre Lebensform aufgrund eines
Bewusstseins Ihrer Lebensform instanziiert
, wird im Folgenden klarer, was das bedeutet,
wenn wir uns vorstellen  die Idee
des Selbstbewusstseins und damit der
Rationalität auf diese Weise, dann ist es
unmöglich, an eine seltene
Lebensform als eine Gattung zu denken, von der
es mehr als eine Art geben kann, dies ist
unmöglich, weil es bedeutet, an
eine rationale Lebensform zu denken  als eine
Lebensform, deren Begriff qua Begriff ist und sein muss,
oder eine solche Lebensform, die von
Individuen abhängig ist, die sich
als Instanziierung dieser Lebensform
und damit ihres Begriffs verstehen, ist sie eine
Lebensform, deren Grundform des
Denkens  es ist die erste Person, also ist
das eine selbstbewusste Lebensform, also ist dies
nach der naiven aristotelischen ISM
das formale Konzept einer rationalen
Lebensform, es ist formal, da es nicht
die Faktoren enthält, die
im Konzept enthalten sind  Da diese Form der
Lebensklaue das Konzept einer Realität ist, wäre das
Konzept einer rationalen Lebensform,
die diese Faktoren enthalten würde, ihr
materielles Konzept, und Michael Thompson
argumentiert, dass das Konzept des hu  Die menschliche
Lebensform ist nichts anderes, als dass
sie der materielle Begriff einer vernünftigen
Lebensform ist, ihr materieller Begriff
unterscheidet sich von ihrem Formbegriff nicht dadurch,
dass der Buchstabe die Gattung beschreibt, von
der die menschliche Lebensform eine
Art beschreibt, in der sie sich unterscheidet  Der
Begriff des Menschen enthält jene
Artikulationen dieses Begriffs,
aufgrund derer der Begriff einer rationalen
Lebensform verständlich als
Begriff einer Wirklichkeit betitelt wird, von dem niemand fragen könnte,
was möglicherweise die Grundlage der
Behauptung sein könnte, dass der Begriff des Menschen sei
der materielle Begriff einer rationalen
Lebensform gut, wenn der Begriff des
Menschen die Form hat, die wir oben beschrieben haben,
dann muss und kann die Grundlage dieses Anspruchs
nur einmal die Anerkennung von
Bewusstseinsformen sein, in denen sich Individuen
einschließlich seiner selbst
als Instanziierungen darstellen  eine solche Lebensform,
deren eigentlicher Begriff von
diesen Formen der Selbstdarstellung für
den Begriff einer rationalen Lebensform
nach thi abhängig ist  Sein Bericht beschreibt eine
Realität genau dann, wenn es
Individuen gibt, die
ihre Fähigkeiten und Aktivitäten als
Instanziierungen einer solchen Lebensform darstellen.
McDowell denkt, dass Berühren die
paradigmatische Aktivität des
Selbstbewusstseins ist, wie wir jetzt sehen können, dass dies
richtig ist, weil es ein Teil davon ist  des eigentlichen
Begriffs einer rationalen Lebensform, dass
man seinen Inhalt nicht
unabhängig von einer Verwendung dieses
Begriffs in Urteilen durch diejenigen bestimmen kann, die
sich als Instanziierungen davon betrachten, es ist in der
Tat, indem sie berühren, dass Menschen
ihre Lebensform vollständig instanziieren, aber
es ist so  ein Missverständnis daraus zu schließen,
dass ein Individuum, das noch
nicht in der Lage ist, es zu berühren, nicht
selbstbewusst ist, sondern das Gegenteil davon hält
, dass nur ein Wesen, das in einem weniger
als konzeptuellen Sinne selbstbewusst ist, dazu kommen kann,
dieses Selbstbewusstsein in einer
Weise zu artikulieren, die ein beinhaltet  Die Verwendung von
Konzepten in Urteilen cha-ching ist eine
paradigmatische Aktivität von Individuen,
die ein Selbst zur Schau stellen  bewusste Lebensform,
weil es die Aktivität ist, durch die
das Individuum den Inhalt
des Begriffs seiner Lebensform bestimmt, die
keinen Inhalt haben könnte, wenn
sie nicht so bestimmt wäre,
und diese Ladungsfähigkeit tatsächlich
erworben wird  durch Übung und Bildung,
denn durch Übung und
Bildung erwirbt der Mensch
spezifische Konzepte und Fähigkeiten, durch
die er selbst in die Lage kommt, den Inhalt seines Bewusstseins zu
bestimmen und damit zu verstehen und zu
artikulieren,
aber Übung und Bildung
ist nichts anderes als die Form  dass die
Ausübung von Fähigkeiten deren
Form Selbstbewusstsein annimmt, dass die und
die in einer menschlichen Umgebung ausgeübt werden
, die in einer Umgebung anderer Menschen ist
, in der einige von ihnen
einfach da sein werden, einige gelegentlich mit
ihr sprechen und andere gelegentlich zeigen
ihr, wie man Dinge so macht, was
erklärt, warum die atras ation einer
rationalen Form von l  Wenn das Leben durch ein
Individuum notwendigerweise die Form
der Praxis annimmt und Bildung somit
nichts anderes als ihre Form ist, hat es diese
Form, weil es bedeutet,
eine selbstbewusste Form zu verwirklichen, wenn man sie
noch nicht vollständig instanziiert und
aufgrund derer man wird  gerade
dass ein Wesen, das es voll instanziiert,
dies so ist, weil die Aktivitäten eines
Wesens, das eine selbstbewusste
Lebensform aufweist, in einer Ausübung von
Fähigkeiten in einer Umgebung bestehen,
aufgrund derer jede Ausübung als solche
einen Beitrag zu deren Inhalt leistet
das Bewusstsein, das sie von ihrer
Lebensform aufgrund des Beitrags hat, den
jede Ausübung Ihrer Fähigkeiten
zum Inhalt ihres Bewusstseins leistet, dieses
Bewusstsein wird
allmählich die Form von Konzepten und Urteilen annehmen,
durch die dieses Bewusstsein sich selbst denken kann
individuelle Instanziierung der
Lebensform, die ihr selbst bewußt ist
, zum Beispiel an das Troja, das jeder
Mensch denkt  Kind Erfahrungen macht, nachdem
es die Lauffähigkeit erworben
hat, die es so viele Monate geübt hat, ist dies
eindeutig ein Ausdruck dafür, dass es nicht
nur das Laufen gelernt hat, sondern dass das
Gehen eine Vorstellung davon mit sich bringt, was
Gehen ist, und dass es sich selbst endlich
dazu bringen kann  Vorstellung
mehr und mehr darüber, dass sie jetzt
Teil der wandelnden Gemeinschaft ist, dass sie
endlich das tun kann, was wir tun, also
scheint es ja so, dass das das
Bild der naiven aristotelischen ISM ist, aber
es scheint eine Abstraktion dagegen zu
geben  Beachten Sie, dass Kanon nun oft
wie folgt ausgedrückt wurde, wenn unser So-
Tilianismus die Rolle der
Bildung im Leben eines Menschen missversteht,
weil er eine Art Essentialismus befürwortet, der
meint, dass das
Wesen eines Menschen, obwohl es sich formal
von dem unterscheidet  Natur jedes
nicht-menschlichen Wesens, da es selbstbewusst ist, ist
es ihm dennoch ähnlich
, da es etwas ist, das
vor und unabhängig von nicht nur w ist  Dass
der einzelne Mensch über
das menschliche Leben nachdenkt, aber auch vor und
unabhängig davon, wie der einzelne
Mensch sein Leben lebt, so wie das
Wesen eines Gesprächs etwas ist, das vor
und unabhängig davon ist, was dieses
bestimmte Gespräch denkt und was wir damit sind
Die Abstraktion nach diesem
Bild ist die menschliche Natur. Die anspruchsvolle
aristotelische ISM lehnt dieses
Bild entschieden ab. Sie glaubt, dass dieses Bild
den früheren
Charakter des Unterschieds zwischen
nichtmenschlichen Tieren und Menschen zutiefst missversteht
der
Mensch ist nicht etwas,
das sich durch seine Gegebenheit an seine Individuen erschöpft,
sondern etwas, das
weitgehend vom Leben dieses Individuums abhängt, von
seiner Erziehung und
Tätigkeit
von
einer neuen Natur eine zweite Natur innerhalb des
Menschen, so denke ich, dass ein Objekt in
dieser Richtung ist  Das Hauptmotiv dafür, warum
man denkt, dass die einzige lebensfähige Form des
Aristotelismus die
raffinierte sein kann, in der Erinnerung
, dass ich sehr kurz argumentieren werde, dass ein
jetzt richtig verstandenes Yin-ISM
nicht nur nicht offen für diese Abstraktion ist,
sondern eine kraftvolle mit sich bringt
Widerruf der Sichtweise, mit der er fälschlicherweise
identifiziert wird, warum der so naive Aristotelismus
die Prämisse leugnet, auf der diese
Abstraktion beruht, er leugnet, dass die
frühere Besonderheit einer rationalen
Lebensform in Begriffen einer
Macht spezifiziert ist, die ihre Individuen haben
Denken Sie nicht, dass der Intellekt eine
angeborene Kraft ist, weil er
den Intellekt überhaupt nicht als individuelle Kraft
betrachtet  eine
Lebensform, deren Begriff keinen Inhalt hat,
unabhängig von dem Bewusstsein, das
diejenigen, die ihn instanziieren, von dieser
Lebensform haben, also der Begriff einer
rationalen Form o  Wenn das Leben ein Konzept ist, dessen
Inhalt von Individuen abhängt
, die sich als
Instanziierung einer Lebensform und
damit eines Konzepts darstellen, dessen Inhalt sie
durch diese Form der Selbstdarstellung bestimmt haben,
so kann man es gemäß einer richtig konzipierten
naiven aristotelischen ISM nicht
erfassen  Die frühere Besonderheit einer rationalen
Lebensform, ohne zu leugnen, dass
es irgendeinen Sinn gibt, in dem gesagt werden kann,
dass ein Individuum einer solchen
Lebensform zu seiner Lebensform als zu
etwas Gegebenem in Beziehung steht, können wir, glaube ich, das
Missverständnis der Anziehung erkennen
klarer, wenn wir schließlich sehen, wie
eine richtig verstandene naive aristotelische
ISM die Unterscheidung zwischen
den beiden Sinnen der Möglichkeit versteht, mit der wir
begonnen haben
und die Aristoteles darin in seiner
Darstellung der Entwicklung von
Lebewesen gemäß dem naiven Aristotelismus
verwendet der Sinn  dieser Unterscheidung ist
abhängig von der Lebensform, die das
betreffende Individuum manifestiert, es
gibt keine  allgemeines Verständnis für den
Sinn dieser Unterscheidung, also welche Art
von Entwicklung sie beschreibt,
unabhängig von der Lebensform, auf
die sie angewandt wird, denn das
, was eine
Lebensform formal von einer anderen unterscheidet, ist gerade
die Art und Weise, in der  Es
verwirklicht sich hervorragend in einem lebenden
Individuum, im Falle einer tierischen
Lebensform sind die Menschen, in denen sich die
Lebensform in einem lebenden
Individuum durch die Sinne verwirklicht,
indem sie Dinge wahrnehmen, die zu
ihrer Lebensform gehören, die sie instanziieren
Ihre Lebensform es ist durch seine
Wahrnehmung einer Gazelle, dass ein Löwe das tut,
was Löwen allgemein tun, wenn sie eine
Gazelle sehen, jagt er sie und frisst sie jetzt haben die
Sinne Organe sie dies erklärt durch
die Entwicklung eines Löwen aus einem Stadium,
in dem er  verwirklicht noch nicht vollständig die
Lebensform in ein Stadium der vollständigen
Verwirklichung hat die Gestalt dessen, was die Bienen
biologische Motivation nennen der Punkt
der Unterscheidung zwischen t  Zwei Sinne von
Potentialität in Anwendung auf ein
Individuum, das eine tierische Lebensform manifestiert,
besteht somit darin, zwei
Stadien eines asiatischen Prozesses biologischer Materie zu beschreiben,
beginnend von einem Stadium, in dem eine Fähigkeit
noch nicht einsatzbereit ist, bis zu einem Zustand,
in dem sie einsatzbereit ist
Wenn dagegen die Unterscheidung
auf eine rationale Lebensform angewendet wird, dann ist
der Sinn der Unterscheidung
anders, weil sie nun auf eine Lebensform angewendet wird,
deren Verwirklichung
in einem Individuum in der Ausübung von
Fähigkeiten innerhalb einer menschlichen Umgebung besteht, von
der jede  Bewegung trägt aufgrund ihrer
Form zu dem Bewusstsein bei, das
das Individuum von seiner
Lebensform hat, weil die
Entwicklung eines Individuums, das
seine Lebensform noch nicht vollständig verwirklicht
hat, zu einem Stadium, in dem es ein
vollwertiger Mensch ist, zu seinem Bewusstsein beiträgt  Das Individuum ihrer
Lebensform hat zwangsläufig die Form
der Praxis und Bildung, dies ist so nicht,
weil sie es sonst nicht tat  Sie werden nicht
vollständig rational, sondern weil dies
einfach die Form ist, die die Aktivitäten eines
rationalen Wesens haben, das
seine Lebensform noch nicht vollständig instanziiert
hat, was es für sie bedeutet, ein Lebewesen zu sein
, erlaubt dies dem naiven Aristoteliker
, die beiden zu kombinieren  Behauptungen, die am
Anfang gestellt werden, nämlich dass ein Mensch
eine formal unverwechselbare Form hat, mit der
Behauptung, dass er als menschliches Kind
jene rationalen Aktivitäten noch nicht manifestiert, die ein
vollwertiger Mensch manifestiert,
wie das Sprechen einer Sprache oder das Berühren, das
Angeben von Gründen oder das Einhalten von Versprechungen des
Erwerbs  einer bestimmten rationalen
Fähigkeit ist zwar eine Frage der Übung
und Bildung im oben angegebenen Sinne,
aber der Intellekt, der
als das Bewusstsein der Lebensform verstanden wird
, das dieses Bewusstsein geformt hat, ist
nicht das Ergebnis von Übung und Bildung,
sondern seine Form als seine Form  es
charakterisiert die Gesamtheit der
Aktivitäten eines Menschen, einschließlich
derjenigen, wenn er ein Kind ist, wenn diese Form
gegeben ist  Ich denke, dass ihre Aktivitäten die Form von
Praxis und Bildung sind, die Elizabeth
Anscombe genau an diesem Punkt zum Ausdruck bringt,
wenn sie in ihrem Artikel über die
menschliche Essenz behauptet, dass die Tatsache, dass ein
neugeborenes Baby sprachlos ist, die gleiche
Art von Tatsache ist wie ein neugeborenes Kätzchen, das
blind ist  und von Gott ist es die gleiche Art von
Tatsache, dass ein neugeborenes Baby,
das eines Tages sprechen wird, nichts anderes als
das Ergebnis seiner natürlichen Entwicklung sein wird, wenn
dies nicht behindert wird, nur dass
wir ein Kätzchen sehen werden, wird das Ergebnis
seiner sein  Natürliche Entwicklung, wenn sie nicht
behindert wird, aber was es bedeutet, sich natürlich zu
entwickeln, bedeutet
für das Baby etwas ganz anderes als
für das Kätzchen. Danke